in most movies the idea of blowing up
the moon with a bomb would be the
craziest thing that happens in moonfall
it's one of the only things that makes
sense everything about moonfall raises
serious questions here are some of ours
at the beginning of moonfall conspiracy
theorist kc discovers that the moon has
fallen out of its orbital path and is on
a collision course with earth he makes
multiple hilarious attempts to get
through to nasa via various avenues but
it's all to no avail by the time he
meets disgraced former astronaut brian
harper he's completely desperate and at
first he gets nowhere in fact he gets
laughed out of the building but then
just when he seems ready to give up on
his quest to show the world the truth
things turn around for kc in a major way
after a visit with his mother gives him
the courage and confidence he needs to
make his voice heard casey leaks his
findings through the media instead of
being a conspiracy theorist unworthy of
trust or consideration he becomes an
anonymous source gifted with credibility
he hasn't remotely earned his findings
circulate rapidly catching the attention
of influential people and putting the
plot of the movie in motion growing
panic puts pressure on the world's
governments to address the problem of
the moon but how did his concerns become
accepted so fast
you're the unidentified source oh yes
it's firmly established in the movie
that casey is the opposite of a
reputable source just because he happens
to be proven right later that doesn't
mean anyone should have believed him at
the start we also know from the scenes
set within nasa that his findings aren't
even easy to unpack even for literal
rocket scientists so how did he get his
message out in a way that went viral and
gained traction what did he do
differently than every other one of his
peers who are labeled as crackpots and
dismissed realistically casey's theories
should have gotten him into the tabloids
at best and then the moon would have
crashed into the earth before anyone
could do anything about it satisfying
not really but it's way more in line
with how this would actually go
in the middle of the film it's revealed
that nasa has known that the moon is not
what it seems for 60 years as told to
joe by mysterious spook holdenfield but
one thing he doesn't make clear is what
exactly nasa did know about the moon yes
nasa knew something was wrong up there
they knew the moon was hollow they knew
there was a terrifying wraith made up of
little nanobots but were they aware of
how it was really built by the original
human race that proliferated throughout
all of space before being wiped out by
those same evil nanobots what the hell
is that the only thing to suggest
someone involved with the cover-up
project may have known more than they
were letting on is the fact that they
developed an emp device for the sake of
defending against the threat the moon
posed that device was constructed to be
used against the black swarm which
implies they at least knew it was a
malevolent force they would need to
contend with at some point budget cuts
be damned but then again given how quick
the military was to settle on nuke the
moon as a solution maybe making a basic
weapon was just the best idea they had
at the time
casey introduces himself as a mega
structurist a conspiracy theorist who
believes that the moon and really all
moons are naturally occurring phenomena
instead they are hollow super machines
designed by advanced alien life forms
the film's climax proves that casey was
at least half right the moon is a
megastructure with a hollow core and
super sophisticated machinery powering
it from the inside but it wasn't aliens
that created it but rather an original
race of interstellar humans these humans
created moons to act as arcs aimed at
preserving the human race after a
devastating war with the artificial
intelligence their society had created
we're shown glimpses of this war and the
destruction it caused when the moon's
operating system teaches brian the
secret history of humanity we see that
many moons were created with the
explicit purpose of seeking out
hospitable pockets of space from which
new planets can be formed and seeded
with human life this grandiose info dump
implies that earth's moon is the only
successful ark having birthed earth and
given humanity a fighting chance at a
future after a war they seemingly lost
with the machines but from earth we can
observe other moons which raises the
question of whether or not every moon
we've ever seen is also an alien
megastructure completely upending our
understanding of the galaxy
at the end of moon fall brian returns to
earth with new knowledge about
humanity's secret history what can he do
with that knowledge to move our species
onto the right cores could he possibly
lead the world to reunite with other
pockets of humanity that may be out
there across the galaxy that's unclear
and he's not the only one who seems to
have his work cut out for him when casey
having sacrificed himself to save earth
has his consciousness scanned into the
moon's operating system he's told they
have work to do with no post-credit
scene to tease what that work might be
the work of explaining what's next is
left to a potential sequel what new
truths about the universe might another
movie reveal with how wild this first
movie gets the sky's the limit
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you